oh hello I'm sorry to call so very early
may I speak to Professor David Wineland
please yeah oh good morning my name is
Adam Smith from the Nobel Prize website
in Stockholm but we have a tradition of
recording extremely short interviews
with new laureates would you be able to
speak for just a very few minutes okay
thank you very much indeed first of all
of course our sincere congratulations on
the awarded the Nobel Prize oh thank you
it I know it's extremely early in the
morning in fact the middle of the night
there what were you doing when the call
from Stockholm came well I was sleeping
and my wife got the call and woke me up
do you recall your initial reaction well
I mean a wonderful surprise of course
yeah just amazing there I imagine is
throwing the house into some kind of
disruption well we probably won't go
back to sleep well yeah yes but I I
guess there's the normal business of
life to run alongside handling the press
that are about to descend on you your
main interest I I gather is developing
far more accurate clocks and that's what
you've been devoted to your career well
that's been the that's been the main
theme yes but there's been many enough
from there including their work on
single atom and the trapping of single
atoms this allows you to observe the
superposition of quantum states a parade
this is basically observing if you like
the frontier between the classical world
where states don't superimpose and the
quantum states where you can have
multiple states at the same time uh well
you might say that that's right yeah how
do you track the anthems now in our case
the atoms are ions charged atoms we use
electric field to hold them in one place
and then you use laser beams to
manipulate them is that correct that's
right uh-huh tell me more please about
why we need more accurate clocks well I
think historically it's always been true
that when we've made better clocks
there's always been an application the
main use throughout history for the last
many centuries is that you know clocks
are used in navigation and the bitter
clocks we have the better navigation we
can do and so that that team has carried
through for many centuries as we make
better clocks that that's still been the
primary application these days also that
the timing the precise timing you know
you know my good clocks is is also used
in communication so but historically the
main use has been continues to be in
their navigation what carrots are our
most accurate clocks now you have this
mercury on clock yeah they're currently
the most the most accurate one is also
in our lab it's based on aluminum and
the accuracy meaning you know how will
we can control the environmental effects
and so on is is it about one part in 10
to the 17 how long can you keep it
running for is it indefinite well so far
these are laboratory devices so they
don't work continuously but they can
work many hours and days to produce
these results so the the other
application that is often talked about
his quantum computing right and does
your work take us a step closer to
quantum computing well I and I think you
might say that but in the same breath
you have to say that it's a long long
way before we have a useful quantum
computer but I think most of us feel
that even though it is
long you know the long ways off before
we can realize such a computer that I
think many of us feel that it'll
eventually happen it's primarily a
matter of controlling these systems
better and better and we work both fair
sir ocean i work on adams and there's
many other platforms and condensed
matter where this might happen but
wherever it happens i think we we
believe it in the long run we we should
be able to control enough to realize
such a device may ask you work at the
National Institutes of Standards and
Technology and it seems to be a hotbed
of the production of new inventions and
indeed Nobel laureates what is it that
so special about this place well I think
you know one of the things is we heard
certainly the people my my management
the people above me have been very
supportive of these things so you know
it couldn't happen without that I think
with the supporter or management and of
course being around very good people has
made the difference must be a very
exciting place to be and indeed it must
be extraordinarily exciting looking at
this new frontier being the first to
observe this new world of quantum states
having previously been observable where
I wouldn't I wouldn't say I wouldn't put
myself in the first you know I mean
maybe you were among the first but but
there's many good people working on on
these things so it's certainly a big
enterprise by now and many people are
working on in this area sure but there
must be a constant thrill of excitement
of feeling you're revealing uncharted
territory well yeah not that generally
true in science to be able to be near
the leading edge I suppose yeah no it's
always been a great really exciting to
be in the video well thank you so much
for talking to us that again apologies
for calling in the very middle of the
night and ok when you come to Stockholm
December we have the chance to interview
a great language we very much look
forward to but so now I wish you the
very best of luck with what does will
surely be an exciting night
all right thank you thank you nice to
speak to you but man